the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our coverage of the
2023 spring chess classic my name is
Julian perlaco and I'm joined by
cancer
this is a tournament for players between
the rating ranges of 2500 through 2600
it is a round robin tournament which
means everybody will play everybody
let's take a look at the rod
a very strong field everyone rated over
2600 except for ABI Mishra who is a very
young talented player the youngest
Grandmaster in history of Chess and he
qualified to this tournament by winning
the last classic Group B so the field is
headed by Sam sebian very strong
American player he just played in the
American Cup and we have some former
students of the Saint Louis University
that are sweets and Benjamin Park and we
also have another Young American player
Christopher you and a Olympic medalist
Nordic back yakuboyeft and those back
team famously won the 2022 chess
Olympiad
and so this is going to be a highly
contested tournament
and let's take a look at Group B this is
the group of players rated average of
2500 so here we have again a pretty
young field we have some local players
like Akshay Chandra we have some
University players Luca who is a museum
student and I also believe that kirgo
lecantor the highest rated player is a
miso student and Kirk azayan is actually
a player I'm very well familiar with he
used to be a student at the chess
Academy in La where I used to teach so
I'm very happy to see him doing so well
he's almost 2500 he's chasing both his
title and of course 2500 to become a
Grandmaster so this is also going to be
a very exciting tournament
yeah and they are playing at the Chase
Park Plaza every day the round time
starts at 1 pm Central
yeah it is a 10 player a round robin so
nine rounds and there are no rest days
so it's 90 minutes for the first 40
moves then 30 minutes for the rest of
the game and a 30 second increment after
each turn throughout the entire game
let's take a look at the schedule so
it's going to be a nine round tournament
the game starts at 1pm no rest days and
the final game will start earlier
because we need to determine a determine
a winner and in case there's a playoff
the playoff will start at 5 PM so we
will have a winner on Thursday April the
13th
and now let's take a look at our keep
matchups of each group so in group a
let's go to group eight our key matchup
of the day is going to be between
some Savion
and
I think I mean gladora versus
and we have an Italian on the port so
let's take a look at how we got here
so e45
do you play any Italians with intercolor
um I played with some with black not a
lot with not a lot with white yeah I
usually play these lines with
this is a close
I would see 3d4 but instead starts with
D3 so basically saying that c3d4 is not
coming
so Knight F6 now C3
so Castle
um there's a lot of setups for black
here but he decides to play with A5 it's
also possible for black to castle castle
can run into Bishop G5 personally I
don't like this bishop G5 positions with
white
um
they don't really do much for me I know
it can be a little scary for Vlog yeah
there's some other setups that black and
choose besides D6 even like I know that
castle is followed by D5 has become like
a pretty popular system for black
yeah the reason I kind of like this move
order is because Castle D5 here here and
I thought this
no actually I don't like this move order
what's the more water do I like oh yeah
I like castle castle this I was just
considering a night video immediately
right in C5 is worse because there's no
Pawn on C3 yeah because if the pawn is
on C3 this is a weakness and now we have
some like 94
um with an attack so there's downsides
to both like which Pawn structure you
choose with either color because once
you put your knight on D2 then there's
no more Bishop G5 so if you like it
Bishop D5 lines then that takes away
that option
yeah I've never fully understood Bishop
G5 because it seems to me that you're
putting the bishop on the wrong side of
the board but obviously there have been
like a lot of high level games in those
systems yeah I played there against Musa
check in a Muslim situation and I lost
but okay in another situation you can't
lose any position okay so in the game
black chose this A5 move and uh this is
a bit of a trendy move
and so other setup is to play with A6
and then Bishop can slide back
uh so do you play with A5 or do you play
with A6
um
I've played mostly with A6
um A5 is a little unfamiliar with uh to
me but I guess it's just trying to stop
this um
A4 B4 thing that white does sometimes in
these positions
yeah so A5 grabs some space in a
innocent and then
black sometimes puts the pawn on A4 and
kind of tries to go after this bishop
and there's this idea Blade Knight bd2
Castle H3 H2 is generally useful most
Knight G4 and Bishop G4 and then there's
this idea where let's say block play is
something like Bishop E6 and then brings
the queen this way after rookie one
uh but in this game
Bishop went back to A7
yeah so the downside of playing A5 is
this bishop B5 move and sometimes white
can do this trade and go D4 and the
setups can be quite annoying for black
because then this bishop gets locked in
and this bishop only six just doesn't
really do much also does A5 prevent
Bishop takes E6 as being like a
dangerous move for white because I know
um in some of these positions as white
like if you play uh Bishop E6 Fe and you
can go like A4 B4 then white sometimes
has some advantage and I guess the pawn
A5 stops this from being the case
yeah usually like as someone who plays
this with white a lot I never liked this
taking only six lines I think it gives
black very easy play because the queen
goes here the Knight H5 Knight F4 I
think black's moves are very easy but
yeah once you kind of fix the structure
here then playing on the queen side
makes more sense because black does have
better play on the both the king side
and in the center yeah so in in that
sense it does stops this idea so when
the pawn is on A6 we do see this bishop
B6 capture so in this position I think
this gives black very straightforward
play because the moves are very easy
especially all these moves I don't think
there's any serious attack because white
play is not a fun Bishop B3 and at some
point white would try to play D4
probably
but okay so in the game Bishop one to B5
so the Knight runs back
um so it's really funny to me that in a
lot of this well in Spanish and like in
a lot of Italian positions the Knight
goes to C6 on move two and sometimes you
move it because it's just misplaced on
C6 so there's this idea and of course in
the Spanish the idea of Knight B8 to D7
and now D4 and this is a very common
reaction when the Knight moves away from
the center we attack in the center
so the Knight goes to G6 to defend the
pawn
yeah what is this bishop A4 move all
about this is a little strange like I
would Bishop A4 wouldn't be my first
instinct in this position
like I would think Knight F1 would be my
first instinct
the fun I think
four okay so the bishop
er
um so the thing with
so I think is they're trying to
reinforce the E4 Square because if you
go Bishop by Fun immediately maybe take
take this might be very concrete phone
sorry
I'm a knight of fun yeah maybe this can
be very concrete take taken D5 and the
Knight goes to E4 with the idea of
breaking the center both with F6 and
maybe C5 and if the file opens and this
bishop opens there's a lot of ifs this
actually can be quite annoying for white
because
um there's a lot of pressure on this F1
and the next move
if Bishop D3 I wonder if I can even give
you this Pawn or maybe I can just go F5
here actually I don't want to play a
five because
yeah
um yes I guess looks like some sort of
French
yeah but this is the ships on A7 which
is a little yeah this is a very nice
French though because let's say if we go
for all of this bishop D5
uh black is just so much play here
I mean this never happens for the price
yeah like black just gets so much
initiative here
the position is just so nice with the
Bishops the rule comes in this king is
just so uncomfortable
so I think Bishop A4 the bishop is going
so I think maybe bishop D3 runs into
some Knight of four with a tempo
and Bishop A4 is just going to C2 to
defend this pawn and now Knight F4 is
not possible because if I was hanging
and this
concrete play is not possible because E4
is defended okay so it's just very
useful to have the Knight on D2 in the
current position yeah and strong players
are very good at this at like making
taking this slow maneuvering moves you
know because the bishop went to C4 and I
went to B5 but it's actually not really
doing anything on B5 right there's
nothing on this left on this diagonal C6
will come probably at some point so I
might as well just move it
and actually I was just looking there's
a game between Dominguez and so from
2022 for several games so C6 was played
Bishop comes back now the Knight is
ready to move
I reach five
so I have to mention there's sometimes
tactics like this against this Knight
but
D4 is hanging in this case so it's not
super impressive I guess
uh it's actually probably just bad
because this F2 Pawn hangs and again
maybe I can concretely play against
um this Pawn because it's also not clear
how white will defend it so this is
unnecessary
so if we're gonna we're already one move
13 there's been no exchanges in the
position so the position is pretty close
so far
and
so let's see the final position where
we're at F6
F6 is not a move I was expecting
looks a bit weakening but because
there's a light Square Bishop probably
is nothing
so Bishop B3 just continuing development
so here we always have to consider if
Bishop H3 is a threat so I think if I
make some nothing move this might
actually
just leads to Checkmate yeah it's tough
to defend here yeah this is just
Unstoppable mate
so that's why he exchanges this bishop
because his Bishop became very annoying
so King grass steps away trade and now
offering a queen trade
um so this kind of trade I think would
be kind of annoying for black because
now this A5 Pawn comes under direct
attack and
um not so clear how to defend it or in
the long term this can become very
annoying the Knight can go to F5 after
this pawn and then maybe it's something
chase this night away
so and immediately the route goes from
doing nothing to an open file and
attacking the say five Pawn
but in the game
he decides not to trade so he plays D5
so it's now we have a very interesting
Pawn structure so it's moved 20 so we've
had no Pawn exchanges so the position is
extremely closed
and but there is a lot of tension in the
center so some puns will come off so
we're probably headed to some kind of an
um we're headed to some kind of an end
game
so here the bar drops quite a bit
there must be some kind of a tactic in
the position
or some kind of
maybe this is hanging
instead A4 is played the glass lights
back
so there's definitely going to be some
clarification in the center here
um
here already
white
um so maybe it takes takes I wonder if I
can play F5
yeah okay so I mean here it already
feels like box position feels quite
comfortable I have to say
this Pawn is going to be very annoying
um
this A2 Pawn might become under attack
so there's a lot of tension in the
center which seems like should be
favoring white because I have Rooks in
the center and whenever you know the
Center opens up having Rooks in the
center is quite helpful
yeah but um it's kind of unclear to me
because I wonder if the Knight on F3 is
misplaced it doesn't seem like it can go
to very many useful squares and also
like if the file opens up the Knight H3
tactics become like pretty strong
yeah if there's if we imagine the spawns
exchanging the Knight H3 will hang yeah
you're right the Knight on F3 is being
controlled by the 66 Pawn so the Knight
on F3 is not exactly the most impressive
piece
and so if you look at the time situation
Sam has 12 minutes left
and we're on move
oh it actually moves have been played
well
have this movie in place
the position and it's plugged to move I
expect him to take only four because I
don't think he wants to allow this take
given
this e-file okay so he did take so I
think Queen E4 the move that I was
playing is actually a blunder because F5
and E4
Knights to take only four
and maybe Queen F5
and H5
yeah these positions are so tricky like
I've played them so many times with
white but I've like lost so many
especially like in bullets sometimes my
position just falls apart
okay so this is the position we're on
move uh 21 so the players
have how much time so white has 24
minutes and black has 12 minutes and
still 20 moves to make
so let's move to Group B and let's take
a look at the pairings there
so we have
um
the key pairing of the day which is
Jason Liang versus dambustion
so let's take a look at
what is going on there so this looks
like another
um
Italian to me so let's see how we got
here
yeah I guess the Italian is pretty
um
pretty common at this level I'm just
trying to Output your opponent uh with
like slow moves instead of like concrete
stuff in the Roy Lopez
yeah it's a very classical opening and
it's a very tricky opening because there
are so many different move orders and
can be hard to prepare and you can also
get very easily confused because you
prepare for some line and then your
opponent
plays a different border and then you
find yourself in a position you're
trying to avoid you're studying the
Italian from black is pretty annoying
because like white has 10 different move
orders and they're all like a little
different and it's hard to differentiate
them at least from my perspective like
why Knight D2 over A4 over C3 over H3 of
a rook E1 you know they're all like sort
of different
um I guess the one thing I understand is
that if white doesn't play C3 then D5 is
less powerful but
um that's the extent of my knowledge
again I said I can say the same for
white I find it very annoying to prepare
and study against well the Italian and
black also has so many more Warriors
it's very tricky so here white plays H3
I guess
um preparing against D5 not wanting to
commit to C3 so D6 again D6 when black
is canceled this bishop G5 move has to
be dealt with
but he decides not to oh so this is also
with A5 so rookie one H6
so this positions are very similar so in
the other game the bishop went to
how did the other game happen
yeah and then Bishop A7 87.
say fortnite F1
Bishop D7 yeah Bishop D7 now there's
this threat of Knight A5 and uh White
like if I play some kind of move for
white now Knight A5 is coming
and uh this bishop is trapped of course
it's not actually trapped but trading
this bishop for a knight is not a trade
that white wants to allow
so that's why the four with a Tempo not
the bishop can slide back yeah in this
position also black doesn't normally
play this exchange this exchange really
favors white because we have this very
classical
on structure in the center very nice
Center so instead like keeps the tension
slides back with the bishop uh this Pawn
is not hanging because for two reasons
can take both with the bishop on the
Knight
tactics on the queen
so instead the Knight went to G3 this is
a very classical I mean very common idea
here the Knight headed to G3
book 138 Bishop to F1
it should be six and the annoying thing
about this position like you make all
these moves and then you get to a
position then you have to start playing
and it's really hard to find uh ideas
after you've made all those necessary
moves
yeah
um he played D takes E5 in the game and
I I would
um I I try my best never to play moves
like de5 and these sorts of positions
but I guess it's hard to like make an
improving move without hating your E4
Pawn because you'd like to play Bishop
E3 but ed4 is probably good for black
yeah and now this Pawn is hanging
because ideally we want to be able to
take what she takes D4 and I think the
reason he played Bishop B6 because I
think here we might wanna take take and
like actually oh no then my queen is
hanging oh yeah yeah
I'm blundering tactics already okay
Bishop B6 seems like a useful move or at
least asking your opponent what they're
going to do and not so easy for white to
maybe night it for no night age were
also not possible the four is hanging so
okay so now we have some clarification
with the center in the center if you
played Bishop D2 D4 was also hanging so
it's easy to hang one Pawn or another in
this position okay the bishop can go
back to C4 or maybe
um
what can we do I don't want to go
Kingfisher because if two will hang I
cannot walk my Knights if I played move
Bishop B5 then black might have the move
Knight takes D4
yeah this was not fun
okay so it takes Quincy too
many seven
so Bishop out and what's annoying with
the pawn being here so this is kind of
double-edged because in the end games
this Pawn might become a huge problem
like if I go Bishop B5 just spawn my
tank but so this Pawn actually also just
hanging if the Rook moves I will just
take the pawn it's a free Pawn but at
the same time my A2 Pawn is hanging
because in a lot of the position in
Thailand if I play Rook D1 you can never
take right because I go V3 Bishop get
shot but here and now you're threatening
commission P3 as well so this one is
actually just hanging which is quite
annoying so it points white might
actually have to play B3
yeah maybe
um what do you think about the move B4
here like as a
as a positional move so they should be
the Rose played before
um I think this is something white is
going to have to do at some point I
think white will try to make as many
useful moves as possible to force
um
to ask black what they're going to do
and not because black just cannot move
this Rook
and just kind of keep the tension on
this A4 Pawn but I do think eventually
before is a move that white is going to
have to play because
um
that will run out of useful moves and
this A2 Pawn is also a Target so I think
we too before it's playable and then
maybe we would continue with the
well actually it's a question if black
has to take maybe they don't maybe it's
actually favorable for black to live
this because A3 is not a move we want to
play right we should be three will come
I think A3 would be favorable for us if
we could play the move C4 in a good way
but I don't think that there's a good
way to do that without giving away
squares yeah if we could get in C4 C5
this would be a great position but
unfortunately it's not happening but I
think in this position again like this
is like whenever these structures happen
there's this idea of Bishop B5 and maybe
a taking on C6 at some point even if
Knight E5 is not possible
hmm
so bishop123 offering so maybe he
thought this bishop is too annoying it's
offering an exchange which makes sense
because this bishop D2 it's not exactly
an impressive piece and now the queen
comes to C5 replacing the bishop on the
dark Square certain Bishops are gone so
now the queen is doing the controlling
of the dark squares
the Knight went to E1
oops I wonder in the previous position
was black interested but probably not um
after Queen C5 was Black's idea to go
something like
A3 followed by Knight D4
was this the intention
yeah this actually does look a bit
annoying
yeah this part here all of a sudden is
super annoying
Chris is like again white has to find a
move so like moving to Rook is never an
option this is hanging
um yeah maybe there is actually quite
annoying because A3 A3 would be met by
before normally but here you can't
and here before is also not a move
because one person and A1 is hanging so
Queen C5 is actually a very nice move
very powerful move by black yeah I guess
91 is just played to defend the queen on
C2
the main intention yeah and I think
maybe chase this
um Queen away and in this kind of
structure if we could put the Knight on
C5 it could be very annoying
so G6
okay G6 controls this Knight
93 Queen goes back
yeah I'm starting to really like Black's
position here I feel like white is
getting outplayed and I know this from
experience because sometimes I play this
position and then my opponents starts
doing things like this and I'm like
it doesn't feel good something went
wrong for me yeah
yeah and Black's uh black doesn't it's
not like doing anything spectacular it's
not like white is getting made it or
getting some kind of attack but black
Smooths are very easy like the King goes
to do someone probably this road can go
to d8 yeah because it's not really about
tonight G3 isn't super impressive either
from White yeah usually this Knight
wants to go to F5 but here it can no
longer do that so this Knight needs to
if it get reroute to E3 somehow that
would be ideal
so Queen one two C1
um I wonder why he didn't play King G7
oh I guess in the queen G5 is
an annoying wolf
so he's stopping that so Bishop E2 okay
so maybe he's trying so maybe he's
trying both to like keep an eye on this
and think of some sacrifices
and at the same time maybe put a bishop
on F3 and start the rerouting of this
Knight so rookie d8 and Rook D1 okay so
this is the final position we have
on the board so again oh black is
actually in a bit of time travel so so
there is increment which means the
players get 30 seconds after each move
but eight minutes for 16 movesets yeah
that's pretty tough and this is going to
be a very long maneuvering game because
we only have
um one pair of pants that's been traded
and one pair of Bishops so a lot of
pieces still left on the board
it seems like blocks play is
um easy but I think maybe white is
starting to find easy moves to make
associated with this idea and also
I would be a bit nervous playing moves
like this because I would have to
consider if this works and I would be as
black I would be very nervous allowing
something like this especially with no
time so I think in a position like this
it's also you know like the Practical
aspect of it meaning who has the easier
moves to make right I've definitely
played some games as black I'm sure uh
these players would avoid this uh from
happening but I played games where I'm
slightly better like the whole game and
then I have no time and then I blunder
attack they can lose
so uh even though black might be
slightly better so the time pressure is
definitely making this a more
interesting game
yeah and
and or Knight F6 was played
yeah
okay but Knight F6 maybe now
yeah Knight of six defends against all
these uh sacrifices on H5 I guess and
also uh this Knight f193 I think was
maybe coming so Knight F6 just keeps an
eye out but I think Queen G5 is a
possibility here now so now E5 is
hanging
and
okay H5 is not hanging but maybe neither
five is an idea
and I think
I think if um after Queen G5 if I play
like Kane all right I guess okay you are
actually going to take money five one
that's annoying well actually if you go
here I'm wondering if you're also lying
this yes you can take I take with a
check now yeah I wanted to go to H7 but
I think you just take on E5
yeah I think I can also take this and
now Knight C6 is coming yeah so Queen G5
can be annoying move and I think white
is also not unhappy with let's say the
Knight goes back
just maybe repeating which is kind of a
funny repetition but
I don't think white is unhappy about
this
so how do I
see if I go and come back I just want to
see the live position because once I
make the moves I don't know how to go
back to my position
okay so Knight F6 was played so I think
Queen G5 is a very logical move and yeah
it makes a lot of sense
from a practical perspective maybe maybe
white isn't even worse
Queen E3 why Queen E3
um
maybe he just wants to go Knight to C5
and kind of tickle his bishop and
Jennifer D1 then Bishop D1 I guess
and if 90 someone again we can't repeat
the position of puts you want
so I don't think okay we have the eval
party eval is telling us black is
slightly better black did manage to get
a lot of moves in since like black was
out playing white but
um I'm not sure like again practically
if plug feels like they're better or
it's just like a position because maybe
this Pawn can become overextended at
some point if Bishop lands on B5
um in some lifetime do you want to take
a look at some of the other games from
either section
yeah well let's take a look at that
again
what the players are playing for
so uh first place prize in the a group
is six thousand dollars second place is
four thousand and third place is three
thousand the total price fund is twenty
two thousand dollars they're playing for
quite a bit of money
let's take a look at the
14 000 total with the fertilizing four
thousand dollars twenty five and two
thousand dollars again a really nice
price fund for such a strong tournament
so there's still um quite a bit of money
to play for in this tournament so let's
take a look at some other day games
since we're in group b let's take a look
at those games so this game between
korkaz Aryan and Victor michalevski
okay Victor michale at some point was
very active in the U.S scene but I
haven't heard this name in a while
probably part of it pandemic related but
so let's see what happens on that F2
Knight F6 and I um I believe I played
with him once I played a king's Indian
and
did not go well for me oh E5 okay
so this is some kind of preparation
giving up the spawn
with the idea is putting some pressure
both on the E file and this Knight on E5
I guess you the people who would play
this move order as black or grinfeld
players is that is that the idea is
white plays this antique grinfeld so you
play this E5 as an ante
um anti anti group anti-anti grinfeld
um
possibly I don't know what his
repertoire is but
uh
yeah E5 so ICL has been played carvana
so some some but I'm assuming these are
all of uh rapid games yeah Muhammad yorf
has played this three times so quite
successfully too yeah but because there
are so many online rapid tournaments so
many so many lines and so many games get
to be played so it's kind of hard to
hard to know
so D5 so Pawn takes apparently Knight
takes is the Knight takes I would be
afraid of 94. okay so Pawn takes
so 95 wow this is very tactical very
early on but you know the white player I
think is 17 years old so I don't think
you would shy away from tactics
so 95
takes and everything is hanging
okay so that's not what happened in the
game so Knight B5 takes takes
okay so why does have a pawn and they
managed to Castle
but I still feel like black has some
kind of compensation here because okay
it's not like these pawns are going very
far the extra Pawn is on the king side
again the bishop on G7 is very nice yeah
it's a very nice Bishop
feels like there's a lot of pressure on
the queen side so white hasn't finished
the development so there's definitely is
going to be
some pressure The Rook will come to C8
maybe at some point black can even take
on C3
95 asking the bishop where it's going
Turtle comes to the center so now C3 is
hanging tactically ship out
this bishop is really getting kicked
around so now it has to go to A4
and queen c41 offering an exchange of
Quints and we know this rule right that
you're down material you're not supposed
to trade but of course these rules are
quite flexible yeah like I guess
concretely after Queen C4 Knight C4 like
all the pawns are hey oh and even once
okay Bishop C4 with Knight D3 I was
thinking Knight Knight C4 because you're
threatening like Knight takes A3
um or like Knight takes B2
but
yeah I guess you have something strong
but Bishop B3 I guess is the idea yeah
and like also it's probably okay here
but not as good as Bishop C4 certainly
so yeah goes for this move work because
now The Rook has to move somewhere
cannot move on a dark Square because
it's gonna run into 93.
so it has to go in some light Square so
let's say D1 and
yeah so now Knight F2 is also a threat
so if I go back why it's so bad what am
I missing
something is hanging right
well
yeah I wonder if the position is just
about after Knight B2 yeah
okay
you know what is your Rook actually oh
your Rook is trapped
Bishop A2 Bishop B2
oh wow what a big ones that's nice and
this bishop also hangs so it's not like
you're losing exchange you probably you
might just lose it wow this is really
bad
wow that was really beautiful it's just
like such a big piece of domination it's
funny right because it's such a clean
pond
it's like there's not it's not an
isolated Pawn it's not a double punch
it's a clean pond with plugs piece
domination is so strong
so in the game he took only five
so so he's
um trying to
minimize the damage here
it's a bishop so it takes takes
should be two Rook here
A4 okay so why it uh is trying to
exchange a lot of Pawns and go into some
kind of a end game where
um
so some this exchange is gonna happen
either so black is gonna say what's
gonna happen it's gonna be four versus
four white will have four versus three
on the king side the C3 Pawn will fall
and uh plug will have a decent pass pun
on the queen side which looks very
dangerous with the Bishops I have to say
probably you'd prefer to be black right
oh yeah for sure because this Pawn is
gonna run like it's very annoying when
you have you know this E6 bishop and
like an a pawn because you can push the
pawn all the way to A2 because the
bishop supports it and with the Rooks I
think it can be very dangerous
so it's a matter of which way we want to
take and also there is some background
weaknesses here so let's say take I
think I have to take
with the bishop because if I take with
the Rook this looks very dangerous to me
yeah I don't
yeah I think I will have to take this
way probably will have to play like
something I should do your H4 so I don't
get made it yeah and then probably maybe
just leave my Bishop here and just like
physically stop the spawn from moving
and just um yeah because it's like pure
drum the pure Rook end game probably
isn't too dangerous
um with the Bishops on the board it's
it's tough so if black wants to make
progress with the a pawn he's going to
have to exchange Bishops
yeah without the Finish
ER comfortable draw because white will
start exchanging pawns and even if you
it's going to be one of the situations
where I give up my Rook let's say the
worst case I give up my rook and then
I'm able to just get a pass plan here
and then you have to give up your Rook
back but with the Bishops the Bishops of
course the presence of Bishop's favorite
is white but
um Facebook but yeah the white Bishop I
think will just stay on A4 and just
refuse to move from here
okay so it does feel like
um
I mean it was a really nice game for by
block so far I have to say this
dominance of the pieces was really nice
and this move Queen C4 I think is um
just forcing this queen exchange or at
least offering the screen has changed I
think it's
such a nice
um
what's the word I'm looking for
educational move
I think this is something we can learn a
lot from
yeah maybe very thematic to this one
yeah maybe taking
a steak maybe hit
he just takes the potential of but um
concretely I think it made things worse
okay let's take a look at a few more
games here whoa
so this is Gregory garageli Canter
versus Luca
okay so it doesn't want to play any kind
of bananas
not today
uh so what is okay
so um
I just heard that we have a result in a
which uh so Christopher you and uh
yakubayov hopefully I didn't butcher his
name
uh have made a draw so the first result
is non-decisive
um
we have awesome yeah 22 Knight F6 this
is like a trendy system with Queen B6 I
believe
95 I was looking at this game from the
corner of my eye when we're let's add
our eval bar so we know what's going on
it's funny because the computer's first
line is like Queen said Castle Queen
side's so unusual to me and just try to
attack I guess
it doesn't care that the Pawn's on C4
it's a castle Knight D4 so okay so
tomorrow to buying but the pawn on A4 is
nice for black because at least black
gets some space on the queen side
I never played this position for whites
even though I'm an E4 player even
against isolated drug and I still Castle
queenside I never played these positions
although they can be quite annoying for
black oh wait how do you Castle Queen
side against accelerated Dragon you
played Bishop C4 or yeah Bishop C4
Bishop B3
okay
so I'm I'm very determined to Castle
queenside in all Sicilians so it doesn't
matter what my opponent does just cast
the coincide and hope for the best
it takes takes okay so this exchange of
pieces should favor Black because on
maruti wine in this position like lock
space and without space
when you don't have space general rule
is you want to exchange if your opponent
doesn't have space you want to keep
pieces on because then they fight for
very limited number of squares so the
pieces don't have anywhere to go yeah I
think black has a nice lack of pieces
for his lack of space okay
because
um
especially here with the light Square
Bishop of course star Square Bishop
would make white a lot happier but with
this Pawn structure and the light Square
Bishop
this bishop is not the most impressive
so Castle Rock AC one
25.
4 okay so probably probably black
doesn't actually want to trade Queens
though because these end games with the
extra space the pawn on D5 might be
favorable for weight I mean concretely
here Rick C7 even just collects a pawn
yeah
this can be quite dangerous to send
games
so F4 okay so white is going to try to
play the play where they have the
advantage so I'm assuming Rook C8
Bishop D4
B5
cringe this is like with a Pawn on A4 is
just such a difference because the pawn
on A7 black has so many problems like
the pawn hang sometimes the queen cannot
really go into anywhere with the pawn
and A4 it's just uh makes such a big
difference in this position yeah now B2
is arguably weak as opposed to
um in other positions where black might
be lacking some counter play
five
back Roxy Five it feels like black
doesn't really have any problems oh
Queen trade yeah but with the Knight on
C5
okay so on the not here the Knight here
is never going to get kicked out so
there's no more C file to be afraid of
so this was actually
and now Rook A5 this is such a nice move
I love Rook lifts Rook lifts are my
favorite thing in chess
and you're getting B2 again yeah this
guy too
three five
so this has to be a repetition right
okay
so the game ends in a repetition yeah
yeah white would be very happy to trade
Rooks to play Knight against Bishop with
the pawn on A4 probably yeah black is
just lost in this kind of end game like
the Keen is the difference between Kane
positions is massive
yeah this King can go yeah here I might
actually also go here maybe kick this
Knight away and then my king just comes
in yeah this is like the best King
against the worst King yeah which is why
I guess at this point black had to give
up and just uh
accept the repetition
yeah but I would say this was a very
comfortable game for black I don't think
black was in any trouble at any point
um maybe black was playing for some
Advantage later
yeah there's something in the opening
maybe white could have done like yeah so
coincide and going for a try which of
course is which you would have done
because
yeah
and then I would like what I would I
would just sit there and debate and be
like if I do this then any coach of mine
would just be angry with me like what
are you doing an announcement like half
an hour and then just do it anyways and
then they'd be like if you're gonna play
it just play it anyways while you're
wasting time
okay so very solid game so I think
um black had a very comfortable blood
draw so I don't think either player can
be unhappy about this result let's take
a look at mishra's game I played Mishra
recently and it was just such a
one-sided game I felt I mean I couldn't
even feel bad after he just knew the
opening better than me and he played
better than me and I was like okay
what can I do it's rough it's just like
at every like he saw everything and then
after he was like you want to analyze
and I was like of course and then he's
showing me this line she was like yeah
but I thought you were gonna do this in
my mind I'm like I didn't even
considered this line but I was like yeah
I was totally gonna do that sure yeah
uh there's been another result in group
a which is between ilionic and Daria
Schwartz that game has been drawn as
well
okay let's take a look at what happened
there so it's sort of some Catalan both
of these are St Louis players so we're
well uh
uh
we're familiar with them here at the St
Louis chess club they play in a lot of
our tournaments and Ilya is I was gonna
say they're teammates but the Ilias
Webster right and lauro is from slew
yeah I think Ilya has graduated but yeah
I believe I'm sorry okay Quincy too
C5
okay
text and text
wow this is a very sharp line so this is
all preparation
so I I know that Doro I think they're
both theoretical
I know Daryl knows his openings quite
well so it takes D5 yeah an isolated
Pawn but quite a bit of oxalation for it
don't really think of Ilya as like a
theoretical player like I think Ilia
plays in a lot of open tournaments and
he just tries to play like a position
like the style is just to beat low rated
players from random positions
um I actually I haven't seen him play a
lot of like really high rated
Grandmaster so this is interesting I
know he's played in the classics before
but
that's actually an interesting point
because the tournaments you play and
actually do affect your style right if
you're playing a lot of low rated
players which is playing a lot of
players higher or at least the same
rating as you
so isolated Pond but I don't think this
is the kind of isolated Pawn that's too
problematic because black will have a
lot of activity the queen of city is
quite misplaced because a rook will end
up on the C file and the screen will
have to find a place to go yeah I
recently played a position that looked
very uh similar to this one as white and
um I found that it was hard to put my
queen on any square like every square
look looks like has some downside right
like the queen is bad on C2 if the queen
goes to A1 what is the queen doing on A1
Queen on B1 might be ideal but
um I got crushed by some Grand Master
and
uh no in um in a norm term in la oh I
see okay
okay so Bishop one two seven
Knights okay the pawn is hanging which
would be six yeah but okay this position
it just feels comfortable for black and
again this is one of those positions I
get an isolated Pawn I struggle I play
it again so isolated fun I'm like okay
this one is too active so tonight goes
to A4 Queen A7
see it just feels very comfortable for
black okay now the queen has to answer
some questions
so the four might be a move at some
point like before
oh wait yeah I wonder why was D4 not
played
I guess it's just or yeah
um oh so Queen B6 is
actually annoying yeah so yeah if you
manage to trade queens and play against
this I think you're pretty happy yeah
this is already tactically problematic
wait but what is going on here this
looks crazy here Knight E4
up two okay so if I take
Queen F2
what am I missing engage on well this
this is the game oh this is the game
yeah oh okay I think yeah so D4 wow this
game got wild so the coin is actually
trapped
no the queen can go to D1
so Queen D1
ah just some kind of repetition
uh yeah
there's no smother mate because after
Queen G1 uh after United yeah Queen G1
unfortunately white has Queen G1 so
Knight of two isn't possible
wow what a game
yeah really
an exciting draw at the end which is
um
yeah this was like a normal position and
then all of a sudden it just got so
concrete so 94.
so Bishop B7 I think we should be seven
just forces all of this right so D4
yeah both both players had to see this
from the start which is crazy just how
good these players are
it's good to be good
so Knight F2 so this has to be Bishop G5
you can't play Queen D4 because C1 hands
and
yeah
uh there's no mate right no
no yeah this is very bad
wow what a game
that was a very exciting drum okay so we
have two draws so far in this section
and let's take a look
this game we're trying to take a look at
well
okay let's see how we got here so oh
yeah we're looking at a Sicilian
Knight F6 Bishop D3 not going for any
Main Line 65
so we're gonna get some kind of a French
nope didn't allow it
what is the system called again it has
some name this bishop D3
um forget it's like after some I am oh
that's what leeches is telling me okay
if there's too many things have too many
names yeah I feel like this is a very
American thing to name every line that's
your name or English thing I don't know
like I didn't have this many names for
openings when I was a kid this is the
Sicilian where they played Bishop D3
yes
okay D4 because probably doesn't want to
allow before themselves yeah the
American name for this open I just
remembered is the kopeck system
oh okay yeah I know
I know the form
96 especially before
okay so the fight is trying to defend
this Pawn
official platform so this kind of looks
like a king's Indian attack but the
bishop is on A4 instead of G2
which um not 100 sure who that will
favor
Bishop comes back okay this bishop is
not the most impressive so far
let's see one yeah um sorry can we go
back before like castles I'm always like
very tempted uh or no no castles for
black
um I'm always very tempted in these
systems to like play G5 at some moment I
don't think it's very good now maybe you
can start with
like
H6
yeah G5 is like a very common thing here
sometimes you can't even Castle Queen
side here and get away with it even with
the c Pawn opening but okay let's try G5
so 95
um
so something like this
you might just get married right yeah I
feel like because I have this and a
bishop on F4 you're not prepared for it
and oops Knight G5 takes takes yeah the
bishop pairs change yeah
push up with slide back so there's going
to be nothing on this file yeah and
opening the position when your opponent
has a bishop pair it's not it's not
amazing yeah that's why I wanted to
start with H6 because I don't I don't
want to trade the uh
the um the G Pawn for the E Pawn I just
want to like attack white but I don't
know if it's super realistic yeah 94 to
D6 might be
might be punishing me for my ambition
yeah no but there's two five ideas
um is a line in the French in those 92
French structures were a black plays G5
and then takes on D4 sometimes or takes
only five uh but you would want the
center to be closed for it I think the
center is too fluid for you to be
getting away with this kind of things
this is a very slow strategic game C4
trying to open some diagonals for a
bishop
and it goes here
the bishop on C2 doesn't look amazing to
me but I guess all of the pieces on the
king side are pretty good for white
and the position is so close at some
point
um so there's going to be some kind of
uh there's Pawn tension right so there's
going to be some kind of resolution that
they get traded on B5 they get traded on
C4 if you go B4 then my Bishop comes
this way so I think it's just a matter
of being patient here
but yeah so far this is
not a bishop uh to be excited about okay
so H5 this is kind of a Karo Khan kind
of
structure so I'm wondering if at some
point
G4 G5 will come but still even the bad
Bishop is safe because this long-term
potential of Bishop is so big that even
in this position you save your Bishop
but like you know it's something like A3
Knight goes back before like all these
pawns come off then
not immediately but at some point then
this bishop can actually
come to life
but black takes
so he thinks this bishop is so bad he
gives up his own so the point is black
has to make sure this bishop doesn't
come to life because that I would
actually I think will hurt them a lot
so Knight P6 P3
get this at some point yes the bishop
makes it to the lawn diagonal then I
would much prefer to play White
but G4 I think this move would excite
you
takes takes uh yeah this is a difficult
decision because you take this weight it
there is where you can take this way you
give this past Pawn Yeah I actually
really like DC over BC though because
like if you play BC like you have to be
concerned about Knight A4 to C3 yeah
which I think matters a lot yeah Knight
F4 actually coming here all of a sudden
this
list of quite a bit maybe an even Knight
B2 and going after this one can be
problematic no this is very unpleasant
so this year I think was forced so A5
trying to play for
oh man playing all these moves with
wait so instead of A4 could white if
nothing to do that uh can I played the
move Knight E1 potentially
yeah I think Knight he wants this
blockade right very typical so A4
okay my idea was Knight D3 but uh yeah
so no no good why is it no oh because
you get Bishop G5 and
the bishop on D3 is not so good yeah I
think my Rook comes in like you're not
ready to fight for against this
makes sense so that's why maybe I should
start with Bishop D2 instead but
it doesn't say
it's interesting move because at some
point
I do get this kind of or if I go Bishop
D2 and I take
you get a protected pass Pawn on A4
yeah I think Bishop did too I taking
care is very much possible because after
this Knight is gone I will take my put
my Bishop on D3 your Pawn can never move
and yes um actually the bishop on B1 now
is like kind of a good piece right like
yeah yeah this vision is actually slowly
coming to life so Rook C7 Bishop no King
H2 yeah I think Bishop D2 is quite
annoying more to deal with because with
this bug play here
I want to I want to take one before if
you move
I think I'm quite happy because now the
Knight comes here and then even if you
do you're right well yeah you can't you
can't do it anymore but you know like
this kind of structures can be so
annoying for black because at some point
I got like 93 F4 I run my king yeah I
got Rook G1 G5 I've played a lot of
caracon and I've suffered in a lot of
end games like this yeah and then even
in the end games right like some because
I know I've played like middle games
where I just like made it my opponents
just pushing my punch but even in the
end games this is super dangerous every
everyone you know who starts out playing
the caracon you hear this thing they're
like you play the carocon because you
want to play End games and the pawn on
H5 will be a weakness in the end game
and then it turns out the pawn on H5
just fixes your structure and you're
worse
yeah so they they lie to you
one of the attacks might be because you
have no like actually the king doesn't
have many Defenders right you just have
this E7 Bishop the youngest Grandmaster
in history doesn't want to win by slowly
maneuvering he wants to Checkmate his
opponent Rick Gio and G4 G5 I never
never mind
yeah and then they're like no no this
one is cleaning so Checkmate but again
this move is especially tomorrow is
quite nice
but now Knight C6 okay so maybe bishop
D2 immediately but Bishop D2 here I
don't know if I want to take note that
this Pawn has moved
I don't know if we take and then like
win the D3 Pawn we just have a two
result game I think so
okay so he won facts okay so I think
this was a big achievement for black to
make sure this okay so this B1 Bishop uh
died again
so it came to life for a minute where
the diagonal then the pond goes there
and I think this is actually a big
achievement for black having the night
on before night on C6 making sure this
Pawn just stays here forever yeah it I I
think they did this also because like
you wanted to play the move Bishop takes
B4 uh to
um put a black Pawn on B4 and now that's
not achievable anymore
um the B3 Pawn will be permanently weak
for the rest of the game
Rook D7
um what move so we'll move 32 so it's
also possible they're just trying to
reach move 40 let's see two okay so
taking this Knight I guess we can
entertain this but this looks terrible
how do we defend the spawn
Rook D3 ah we'll just go after this guys
right
oh yeah and then Rick now the other
route to D3 could cause major issues
yeah this pawns this is fall apart it's
just
just interchanges in the position and
all of a sudden Everything Changes right
because at some point in the night on F3
was here assisting with just G5 push and
but now things switch we're going to the
queen side and all of a sudden this
Knight is not very well placed
well Bishop Bishop C2 was actually
played
but
he thought would be
it from like you need to do this so he
went here he he might be in serious
trouble now black hasn't played Rick ba
yet but I think if black finds the
sequence then
then White's defensive task is not going
to be super easy
okay there has to be a way for me to see
the live position right without because
when I had analysis like I can't tell
the the live position is when it's like
read and outlined like that oh
okay so maybe it's deciding between
rugby 7 and Rook B8 I don't know if
there's a difference it doesn't feel
like there is yeah I don't know why
there would be apparently there is a
difference wow
why would it matter that's actually
insane
so Rook V8
so with rookie three here Rick Waits
there's something back rank related or
oops okay so let's see so rugby Rook B8
was the correct move right so apparently
this is not as good
what could be
so white should play Rook E3 anyway
is this
and then after Rook C2 in the previous
position it wanted Rook A3 from black
and it claimed plus two
but now Rook A3 oh there's a trick on
The Rook okay okay
seven
yeah I would uh I would guess so it
would be like 50 50 if I played this
game
this side and then uh it's just one
better at some point
okay so yeah so the position is actually
quite bad here
for um for white right so
I love this
so where are we so Knight D2 was played
okay so it defines the pawn which makes
sense
and now
so apparently this was a mistake let's
try it
I need to learn how to use this
variation okay so do I have no Bishop G5
runs into F4 again can I have 94 what is
the problem here
Rook D3 Maybe
so if Rook T3 then Rook E3
no but here everything is suddenly
defunded so now I'm just gonna win this
Pawn Yeah black played Bishop G5 I guess
he didn't care about F4 or maybe so if F
oh F4 Rook D3 so moving this Pawn now
there is no longer rookie there so it's
actually quite clever so now I'm
assuming that I have to take and he'll
probably take on
no he will check
so Rook C2 is highlighted so it's the
game
so Rook theater is the game I'm learning
finally yeah so oh so he's gonna just
take on C3 and take on D2 and then white
will uh what will be in some trouble
just easily won this position
so if I put a knight on D4
but this guy goes back I presume
and uh so
um I've just learned that in group b uh
Chandra has defeated dagger party and we
will be talking to him shortly so that's
uh
our first decisive result I believe it
is our first decision result and we
actually
take a quick little
quick lookship F4 I think
I Bishop F4 is not really moved here in
92.
very novel system
four
I mean the system usually the bishop
doesn't land here it's usually on B2
right they try to go B3 Bishop E2
oh I'm sorry what am I missing yeah yeah
that's a very common idea doing that
I have to say this position opening up
with these two Bishops here
looks a bit dangerous 94.
oh wow wow yeah but there's gonna be
some 96 check right takes takes 96 yeah
you see five the bishop on C5 looks
really good this Rook is going on A7
so I I think tactically oh there is such
a nice move for oh your back rink mated
nice
yeah so you just have to lose the
exchange okay yeah the point there uh
the point there was if you um play Queen
takes D1 which you would like to do
um you're not actually safe because
rookie 8 which would be the normal
defense runs into Bishop E7
and yeah Rick d8 and it's over
well that was a really nice game by
akshat in a very smooth Victory so we'll
be talking to him shortly he will take
um take us through this game a bit more
detail uh let's see if
um
our mistress game if there's been
developments oh that was funny so the
bishop went
to before
um so the bishop one before is quite
strong I hope it doesn't get stuck here
so okay it's a very nicely defended
piece so I think Knight D4 is coming
Bishop A3 pick up this pawn and then go
back and go after response I think this
should be winning just might take a long
time yeah I think
um Blackwood ideally like the bishop on
D4 and the Knight on B4 but both if you
can put both of your pieces on those
outposts you would be happy
yeah I just wanted a knight on D4 so I
could take this Pawn because once I take
this Pawn everything is hanging so
that's why I wanted to go Bishop G5 so I
could put so like I could always be
eyeing this pawn and take this pawn it
doesn't even feel like it's two pieces
for a rook it just feels like Europe a
piece because of how good Black's pieces
are gonna be
this Rook
try to hang on to pawn somehow okay but
we're gonna move um we're gonna reach
move 40 in just one more move
and the players will get 30 more minutes
so this I think this game will go on for
a bit
and so we have two results we've seen
this savions game like see if there is
developed well that's this is headed
towards to draw somehow right yeah
probably
so where did we live off we live off a
long time ago we were around here right
so he took with the night
instead of your queen F5 he decided to
play Ed yeah so he did clarifying the
position Knight takes
who takes C4
8-3 so this is again very concrete
well this queen went on an adventure I
would be very nervous if my queen was on
stage three here
it takes takes
I would be very nervous here with vlog
okay grows upon
okay I think now black is relieved
96. oh my God there's so many nights
like what is this
yeah nicer it's very rare to have all
four nights on the board and end games I
think yeah but this will end in a draw
yeah so this Pawn will fall and it
didn't Rook get two Rooks and three
verse two Rooks and three probably as
drawn as one rook and three verse one
rook and three yeah but I think it's
Point here there must have been
something for white 95 it just feels
like
okay this nights are very well defended
so what should we do
Queen
try to mate work two three like the
night goes back
right maybe some H4 at some point maybe
it's possible yeah yeah because if you
play H5
maybe you have to write because I think
if you allow H5 that's actually if
you're large five at night is trapped
you don't have 97 so I think you might
have to go H5 but this is I would be
very nervous about this one your kids
feel so bad unfortunately I don't have
Queen F3 like I just don't have a good
way of attacking this maybe yeah like
Rook G3 Queen E2
could be pretty annoying yeah this guy's
hanging 22 is coming about 2 runs into
something right or maybe Knight G7 even
in some position oh yeah I would be very
nervous yeah 22 Knight F4 I guess black
is alive
for now
okay and the final game that we have
apparently white is already winning so
we didn't see this game at all so this
is Daniel dardo versus Benjamin Bach
oh let's see so some kind of an English
so I will just play through the opening
because I'm curious to see about
how we got to this position
again isolated Pawn but here I think
this isolated Pawn is actually quite
weak
so Bishop out Bishop comes back
and
night goes to D5 taking this is not
ideal
because then B7 hangs
okay so we'll I'm just playing to see
how we got to the position that we have
on the board okay why wanna buy one upon
and
Rook B7 okay this looks very bad
it can goes to h8 Knight F4
oh it feels like black is barely hanging
on here tactically Bishop D4 this is not
an exchange that black can be happy
about because Bishop versus knight and
this Pawn is running this bishop will be
assisting this pawn and this Knight
um it's probably eventually going to
fall
and why white is just up a pawn here
with this very dangerous pass Pawn
Rook C7 now black has to find some kind
of an outpost for the Knight if they
play D5 which is possible the Knight is
defended but the problem is now
uh The Rook is cut off
so we exchange this and we are going to
see
so the position we have on the board is
a bishop versus knight end game
okay winning another pawn and okay so
this Pawn will Queen eventually and
white will be up a piece and just will
simply win the game
and we do have the winner of the game
akshat Chandra with us in the studio
actually congratulations on your win
thank you appreciate it uh take us to
the game so I start the opening and I
saw this move Bishop F4 which is not
very common so it's yeah I'm yeah I
prepared something here I just wanted to
avoid like the main lines that go after
Knight F6 929 C6 there's a lot of theory
there and I just wanted to get something
Fresh So what's the idea behind this
bishop perform move I just developed a
knight D2 and it's not easy for black to
decide which setup he wants to play okay
so he played D5 which looks very natural
so Knight D2 Queen six
Castle
um
so where do you think things started to
go well for you
I think what he played with Bishop Queen
B6 and Bishop Basics is already dubious
I couldn't remember why
but
with the king in the center it's
extremely risky to play on the queen
side like this probably he had to go uh
probably just Bishop p7 instead of Queen
B6 try to get his team to safety that's
probably the most accurate
right and then Bishop B7 just you get
like one of those normal structures in
the Sicilian uh I wouldn't go see four
here but I'd Castle oh yeah okay and
then you play with E5 and it's just a
game
and do you think the bishop on F4 does
it benefit you having the bishop here
yeah I think he does it uh covers the G5
Square as well in some cases you go like
Knight f3h4 Bishop G5 Knight G5 so
Bishop
yeah something like this
oh H6 probably already probably black is
play something like F5 here
yeah like Queen E2 looks better for
white yeah it looks Pleasant
so instead he played Queen B6 so when
did your um preparation end after Bishop
B4
I vaguely remembered Bishop E7 was like
the only move to not be much worse I
mean it's still worse for black but I I
think all the other moves are just like
much much worse
so it's kind of frustrating when you
played Bishop before that I had knowing
what to do because it's probably close
to losing for uh for black I don't know
if what I played was correct there are
many options but it seemed decent enough
so did you spend a lot of
yeah I did because uh I thought they
should just like lose on the spot
somehow but he has this nice idea of the
etix D5 Knight takes d flat it's like
the only move to keep him in the game
because if C takes D5 Queen A4 check
followed by C5 just wins a piece
are actually hard to face this queen A4
move to this position it's always a
threat and if he takes with the epon
then he just opens up the E file and
that's bad yeah C5 yeah that's very nice
yeah taking with E4 upon this is yeah
right I also have C5 in between E2 which
is a nice trick but like even if I
didn't have that
there's always Rook if you want check
and Black's King is in trouble
but after Knight D5 you must be happy
yeah but uh it was there was actually a
really nasty trick for black I think so
I spent a lot of time because I was
trying to make bishop E5 work but he has
oh wow and it's just a big mess like I
couldn't work out everything over the
board like yeah I take take
Queen E5 yeah Queen A4 Bishop takes D2
take on C6
King E7 Queen H6 and I was unable to
evaluate this position clearly I mean I
figured I should be better but his dark
Spirit Bishop's also pretty decent and
his Rooks are coming to the game so yeah
if you had rookie one right yeah yeah so
Queen V7 is a huge threats or something
like Rook p8 yeah
it doesn't look very clear
so I figured Bishop G3 was good enough
then because if he goes 93 now I can
take and I have Knight F2
so Bishop G3 93 fe3 Queen E3 Knight F2
and which
oh sorry Bishop F2 here and then
whichever PC takes I have Queen A4 which
just wins yeah it feels like
yeah
okay yeah exactly yeah but this position
with this king and the other two Bishop
is just so nice Rook d8 94.
I don't felt like the whole game he was
just barely hanging on
yeah I knew I should I knew I should be
better like it still wasn't easy to
figure things out over the board like
even here like the computer string plus
four I didn't think I was plus four
during the game I thought maybe I'm like
plus one and a half to plus two so what
did you consider here well 97 came as a
big surprise I didn't expect that at all
I thought he would go Queen D4
after 94.
because I thought if he moved the Knight
back it's just uh extremely passive yeah
I was gonna play Queen B3
but there are some tricky lines to work
out like I always have to calculate some
discovered night moves and
but yeah something like nights where
somewhere
I'm not sure to be honest I just figured
I'd play Queen B3 and I didn't see a
decent move for him so I didn't really
go further so like was if I Castle well
there I just go with D1 now okay sorry
and I support the bishop yeah
and everything's just hanging for him
yeah yeah this is
yeah this is very tricky
sorry
now it has to go so maybe some night
trick so now you have to take right
no I took him before here and I have 96
now these dark squares are extremely
weak
uh can I take this way hopefully it goes
I mean I've knighted you five but
probably oh my God there's literally
every piece is hanging
yeah this is bad so you want it here and
96 yeah that should be enough right yeah
I mean just winning an exchange should
be winning
so instead
also probably I should just add here
that after yeah he can play 93 because I
just switched position uh the previous
move yeah 93 I take and go Knight F2
which is nice oh this is very much and
you can take on C4 but I just get too
many pieces for the queen
they should be winning
slowly along tangle like King H1 get my
9 to the game and oh he only has a pawn
again yeah no he has two puns but okay
yeah but his pawns are like extremely
immobile so yeah you should be waiting
for white you have like nice outfits for
your pieces yeah this is very unusual to
have this kind of kind of yeah between
two Pants versus refuses okay so 97 was
played and A3 so he went for this yeah
this is all forced takes
if he takes on D6 it just transposes the
game
okay so he took it right here
yeah Bishop C5 is important
so did you think you're already winning
here or you just started I thought it
was much better I wasn't sure about
winning
uh Queen the age Queen F1 yeah and
Castle Queen the one is a nice trick
yeah Queen they want is such a beautiful
move
um I didn't expect him to Castle though
I thought he would play notes yeah I
mean it looks terrible obviously with
the king in the center but then maybe
you could try to hold on here and try to
play for F6 later
yeah I was just gonna exactly play Rook
D1 and then bring my queen to like
the center or like the Queen's side the
queen C7 I guess they're like 22. yeah
pretty much anywhere I can move my queen
and then try to play for B5 or maybe
even Queen G4 ideas to like attack the
king's side and force some weaknesses
yeah that's not so he has to play like
97 and B5 is very strong yeah it should
be lost but I thought maybe that was a
better try since in the game he's just
losing an exchange immediately he
probably did he miss quindy one uh
probably because otherwise I don't think
he would go for it yeah because if not
Queen demand yeah because the Rook dick
says rookie eight I mean I'm obviously
better but it's not winning by any
stretch of the imagination the knight's
coming to D5 yeah that is actually
probably the best position he said in a
while yeah exactly no Queen demand is
just such like I really like this kind
of quietness
and we already showed that the point is
that takes takes there's no rookie
because of back rank
and after Queen D1
and I actually didn't see the rest of
the game so your conversion yeah
unfortunately foreign issues
[Music]
um yes Queen can never get activated
which is important yeah I always have
Queen D7 Rook C7 ideas if he takes on B4
yeah that's King
Instead This was plate G3 yeah just
stopping in United four ideas I know my
queen enters doesn't have moves
thanks
yeah now his position just collapses oh
so you just collected everything yeah I
just took the pawn and started pushing
the b-pawn
four and then Rook C6 okay and then
you're just gonna trade it exactly oh
wow yeah this was a really nice uh nice
game this windy one
such a nice woman
um well this great start for you and
congratulations on your win and who do
you play tomorrow I play I think Luca is
black
okay well good luck in the rest of the
tournament hope we see you back here
again thank you
okay and that was akshat's Chandra the
first decisive result of the day that we
have and we will continue looking at the
rest of the games there are still quite
a few games we haven't looked at I
believe we've seen all the games in
group a actually we can see this mystery
game not a lot of developments the
players original 40 uh we saw glitter
versus Savion so this three versus three
there's actually no draw before move 40
but they reach more 40 so I'm expecting
a draw here and Daniel tarda versus
Benjamin book this should be over
any moment now this night is trapped
here if the Knight goes to G2 King F3
picks up the night and if G5
um even
this should be a win but even this is
with the two connected pass Pawns uh
very comfortable win for white so this
if there is no result yet then we expect
to see a result here
so we will have at least one decisive
result in group a
and let's go to Group B still a few
games we haven't seen
so we saw Kirk versus
quite a few developments in this game
so the entrance says it's equal but
there's a past pun but the good thing
for white is that some pawns have come
off the board so let's see we left off
somewhere around here
so the Kings come back because the King
on H1 actually is giving some background
issues for white
so King Kong joins the game and white is
managed to trade funds with F4 I think
this is actually quite good trade for
white because with F5 we can kick this
bishop away from this comfortable F5
Square A6 Square
and now we get to exchange the Rooks
E5 so I I think also I
I have to mention so this is the wrong
Bishop for this Pawn so if we somehow
magically exchange Rooks exchange all
the puns and give up this bishop and put
the king here
uh this will be a try and this is
something to actually always consider in
this kind of Bishop and games
because you have to think about it
about this bishop so is there any other
games you haven't seen yet so we saw
this game right
um Jason Leung versus Damascus so with
this one we left off a long time ago we
haven't seen the
um the Felix versus uh glove game I
guess okay
so let's see where we are in this game
and
let's see so no we didn't see this much
so we left off somewhere around here so
913 someone probably stopped Queen G5
so Knight goes back it's kind of a funny
move
ment that's something we see very often
yeah
the white plays Queen C1 all of his
pieces are on the back rank nope
it's a nice comeback
yeah patience is key in this positions
it's a 96 and that can go to F4 or C5
position doesn't seem so bad for white
anymore yeah I I don't know how I feel
about C6 because it gives a Target but
maybe Rook D5 is annoying also is this
yeah
F4 and E2 hangs with a check so I don't
have any
adventurous jumps
so Queen goes three three
logical move
so so far
King G2 F6 yeah actually
it
sort of looks like White's plain black
and blacks play and white like this one
structure yeah yeah like doesn't this
seem like well explain the white side of
an Italian yeah it seems like this game
was quite comfortable for block for a
very long time
and 91 takes takes
oh that was a nice move Queen G8 here
apparently but that's a nice move I love
this kind of moves
yeah Queen G8 to go to all the way to A2
that's right
I mean it feels like
it's equal but also feels like it can be
annoying for white still like this is a
target ah it probably wants to play
Queen E6 which seems like more of a
normal
move to make like this pun structure
can favor should favor Black in some
positions if this Knight is far away
if we get some kind of a queen trade if
we imagine like if the Knight goes to F3
let's say if there are no queens right
then something like this can happen
and of course there are coins on the
board so it's still Pleasant for black
black has the better pieces the queen
controlling the D file the Knight on C5
is better than its counterpart only one
and this Pawn structure is just better
for bug so it feels like slightly
Pleasant for black but probably nothing
can go here keep an eye on this night
try to bring this Knight into a game
probably um maybe bring this King play
Knight D3 just try to trade everyone
play some kind of a king and pun in game
yeah I would suspect this ends in a draw
so you said we haven't seen this game
we've not really happened
so let's see what's going on here this
looks like
oh I was gonna say it looks like Carol
Connor French but yeah so this is a very
topical
uh so usually they avoid the small
border because of CDD Bishop G5 and okay
Bishop F4 yeah actually I I was under
the impression I don't know if this is
true that Bishop F4 is supposed to be
inaccurate because
um black can play the move Bishop D6
here like um there's this uh line that
um they play in the Queen's Gambit
without Knight F6 so like if you go
before Knight o6 black plays Bishop E7
sometimes like yeah D5 D4 Bishop E7
and then white takes on D5 and goes
Bishop F4 ah to punish right and then
quote unquote yeah and then after C6 E3
black still sometimes plays the move
Bishop D6
but so you get this line up a Tempo if
you play
uh Knight F6 and they go Bishop F4
I mean Bishop G5 is a huge line here
that's played a million times but uh
Bishop F4 is not as common so C6 C3
Bishop F5 yeah yeah this is uh if black
gets in all this move because when
sometimes we see this Carlsbad position
where black when the Knight is already
on D7 so this Knight has to go on an
adventure for this bishop to get out so
for the bishop to get out immediately
it's quite comfortable
so Bishop D6
okay so tickling this one like this
seven yeah Beach is also hanging
yeah this kind of Trades uh with the
King still in the center probably is um
dangerous
yeah I'd already prefer to play Black I
think see one three six instead Queen
goes to a five
Castle
94.
yeah this seems like white is playing
quite risky here D1
yeah we're just playing against White's
pieces
um yeah this position looks very
uncomfortable for white like the
opponents see like the structure for
black is worse but everything else about
the position seems better like my
Knight's better than White's nine my
picture is better than White's bishop
and all my Rooks are on the B file
what's the queen on A5 so Queen C3
rookie FP yeah this looks very nice like
how does white ever bring their Rooks
into the game it should be three
oh so I just learned that Daniel Darda
has defeated Benjamin Bach in the a
group and we'll be coming in for an
interview uh soon
yeah that's the game that we saw with
the bishop versus knight so we're
expecting that result Queen G6 but why
not it's taking so check
house wait not getting mated here like
King G2 there's gonna be some 93
somewhere
I like rugby six yeah it does feel like
White's in massive trouble I like Rook
B6 and C5 a lot that that seems like a
nice plan I love it's a rook lifter
wait so if takes takes no but this this
cannot be good
like this King
so you didn't take on F3 probably he
didn't see maybe he didn't see anything
concrete and he thought Queen G6 is nice
so 91. okay threatening mate maybe he
thought he has something here
okay but uh looks like the worst is
behind for
for white
so this gets exchanged okay so white
survived this
and mainly because the C4 Knight is
hanging so taking only four was not
possible
because this is hanging
so this Rooks get traded King goes back
Knight comes into the game
and let's see let's just see what's the
current position
but now it feels like the position is
actually quite nice for white compared
to what we had when white just couldn't
move any of their pieces
H4
so I think they're trying to reach move
40 no but uh with this Pawn
and see one
it was just going back and forth
so we reached move 40 and this is the
current position we have on the board
but we will go back to our game
um
between
wait am I in the wrong group
sorry
uh we do have a guest with us who won
his game oh that's the game actually
have Daniel TARTA congratulations on
your win thank you thank you um so it
looks like you had a very smooth Victory
please take us through the game
okay C4 C5
um I checked a couple of things but here
after E3
um he played Bishop G7 I mainly checked
positions after a knight of six D4 takes
takes D5
and here like you have a completely
different game but he kind of um went
for a different move order he went
Bishop G7 which allowed me to go D4
straight away grab the center take six
and here he played the Knight of six
so
um if I were to go Knight F3 now black
would go D5 and you get a very big line
that I hadn't really checked before the
game
so I was trying to make use out of the
fact that you went for a different move
order and he doesn't get D5 straight
away so I went D5 myself here
it made some sense to me during the game
uh here he went Castle Knight of three
and uh D6 but uh during the game to be
honest I was thinking I was more well
I'm not really scared but I was thinking
he should have gone for E6 instantly
instead of these six yes because that uh
that didn't give me uh the option that I
had in the game so in the game he went
D6 basically
uh he went D6 with black yeah I played
Bishop E2 and he went E6
well after Castle he would take D5 let's
say and after C takes D5 we would get
some symmetrical position like castle
edcd and the position is quite balanced
right
and this is what he was aiming for
uh but he gave me the option that I
could take D takes E6 now okay and your
point is if he will go C6 here and you
take he can just take it yeah exactly
and now Knight C6 and black has a very
nice uh center right so
um yeah I assume that he was afraid that
I would push D6 myself yeah that was
gonna be my next question
six
yeah but maybe he has some uh some
strange ideas like maybe even a queen
somewhere Queen A5 or queen B6 but also
exactly yeah or B6 immediately and
Bishop B7 and develop his pieces
straight away and uh it's not clear to
me whether my Pawn on D6 is such a
strength or reliability like it can be
targeted in the future I think
yeah it's really hard to determine these
things
I use quite some time but at the end I
went for detex E6 actually because uh I
think it's
well the position that I got in the game
looks very pleasant to me after a bishop
takes Knight D4 important move because
Castle's black has the option to play D5
and he gets rid of his weakness
so I went Knight D4
he went rookie eight um yeah probably a
good move because if you were to go
Knight C6 I would take the bishop and
then castle and black has these hanging
pawns which looks a bit uh weak and
strange also because white has the
bishop pair
so rookie 8 I castled first uh Knight C6
and I took the bishop
Rook takes and this is also quite nice
for you right with the bishop here yeah
I thought during the game um well I
understood him I underestimated this
position a little bit because I thought
during the game I had the bishop pair I
have the better Pawn structure also but
his pieces are his pieces can get quite
active quickly actually
um as in the game I played Bishop G5
let's say which I was not so happy about
why not because
um well in the game he played H6 but
actually I was a bit more afraid of
Queen A5 here
which I hadn't really checked too well
yeah so Queen D2 was like it's like a
normal move let's say but Knight E4 was
the problem and after Knight takes E4
Queen takes D2 I is the move that I
missed and I cannot take with a knight
because Rook takes E2 so you don't have
a good way of care and Bishop takes Z2
there's Rook takes E4 and problem is I
cannot go to D3 to defend the C4 Pawn
because Rook D4 yeah it's unfortunate
actually yeah very yeah but uh yeah
Queen A5 was a bit uh an annoying way to
kind of discordinate my pieces somehow
do you have to go back maybe yeah
exactly yeah this also when I we spoke
after the game he said that Bishop D2
was the move that he didn't really like
but still maybe you can make some move
like I did
well I don't know for pizza you can go
to a better Square maybe like B6 and
then you need to calculate options like
Knight D5 also of course but uh still
like Bishop D2 was not really a move
that I I was saying like this yeah
exactly yeah yeah it's getting very
sharp yeah and this is not something I
wanted to calculate because it looks
like I have a very nice positional
Advantage Bishops and so why not just
Bishop B3 then yeah in well in hindsight
okay I would have played this but
actually it was nice in the game because
he went H6 and now I went to E3 and
somehow the H6 Pawn is uh like I can go
Queen D2 with Tempo let's say and the
pawns a bit weak actually you ended up
winning this Pawn at the end uh yeah
exactly exactly yeah so Bishop G5 I got
some useful so 94. yeah
um yeah Knight E4 well good move of
course
um if I were to take on e4 and Rook
takes E4 I don't really know like uh
what my
plan is here like how do I put my pieces
because if Queen D2 then Queen H4 and
some Rook E8 some Knight D4 someday it
can get get a bit annoying I just please
play you can get even some attack at
some point and my pieces are not um
they're a bit cramped up and I cannot
move very freely so Knight D5 was a kind
of an attempt to
well we'll just say I have a strong
night and I keep some pieces on the
board
he took B2 which I thought was not a
good move actually
I was happy to see this I was more like
well I think you should have made maybe
some queen move here well I thought so
during the game um like Queen A5 for
example and I don't really know what to
do
it's hard to find a good move for me
so your Pawn is your Pawn is oh maybe is
it it's not really necessarily hanging
but um like he can just go rookie E8
with other rook and like in worst case
go back with a queen and he has like uh
all his pieces are perfectly placed and
I don't really know what to play because
Queen C2 if I were to go somewhere the
Knight D4 is always an issue yeah you
don't want to give up exactly I don't
want to give up especially my dark
squared Bishop
[Music]
um
yeah so maybe this was something to
think about if I were to go Rook B1
let's say then maybe rookie eight like
maybe
maybe yeah exactly and the rugby wonders
Queen takes eight uh no not Queen takes
A3 sorry but then uh A3 is hanging like
later in like in some lines
for example Knight C3 somewhere also an
option even like and I have to calculate
already
it's very tough
um yeah but the good thing is this H6
Pawn hangs in all those lines yes
okay yeah then you ready to B2 Rook B1
and here he went back I was thinking
like Knight C3 I was calculating
actually because first I thought I was
winning instantly with Queen D2 but I
forgot that he can take E2 with check
action okay and okay position is like
nothing special yeah
really
it still feels Pleasant for you somehow
very very but I can also um just take C3
and then B7 and I have a bishop pair
instead of going into this right I can
just um take C3 and B7
yeah exactly because uh I can even
choose which one I take but I think B7
is better
just to break apart the pawns and like
give some ideas black exchange some
pieces this way at least maybe he can
try hanging on but
I'm not sure
okay so instead he went back and you
were happy with this because of the
bishop parent yeah well he kind of just
gave me like um he gave me like easy
play because before my pieces were a bit
cramped up and yet he was playing with
activity in Knight E4 opening the
diagonal of his Bishop
but now he activated my Rook actually so
all my beasts are kind of doing
something and coordinating
and here he played Rook B8 so
well the thing is I want to I would like
to play Rook C7 here but the problem is
that it fails tactically due to Knight
C3 so I have to take I think or I don't
have to but I I was relying on my next
move actually yeah it was a very nice
move for forcing uh black to play F5 and
weaken his structure because if rookie
five there's Bishop F4 and if rookie 8
Bishop D7
this is very annoying and so he has to
block with the pawn actually
yeah once your pieces come into a game
actually calculated instead of Bishop F3
also Knight F4 and some very complex
lines with black has strong move
Intermezzo Knight C3 now I think
and some Queen F3 stuff there's 95
always so it's not really working my
gosh oh yeah yeah it's very um
oh your queen doesn't have a square yeah
exactly it's very unfortunate that's uh
for this Knight T3 because otherwise
Knight F4 is interesting I think yeah
this is yeah exactly yeah it's
unfortunate okay so Bishop F3 King H7
Queen A4 so this is all very comfortable
for you yeah 95 is not the best move I
think also I thought Queen B7 during the
game
it's uh it gets also like black would
like to play Knight D4 here but the
problem is um I can capture this and
queen D7 check I win The Rook yeah it's
a big fan big problem so therefore Queen
B7 was maybe a good idea I'm not sure
once again but uh
I mean if you want we can
yeah after Knight E5 it's well fairly
easy I think yeah because this Pawn
structure changes just so nice for you
yeah I don't even have to take A7 but
you know it's bad for your opponent when
you don't have to take a free Pawn yeah
yeah exactly but uh okay
took
uh taking a chain best move
here I went for Knight F4 I thought it
was better than the computer gives
actually I thought it was like
they don't have A4
yeah well Knight F4 I just played
because I saw a concrete tactical
variation as in the game right but I
think I think this line that you went
for this is well he had to play Knight
E5 I think only chance but it's still
yeah but I think it's still like from
practical point of view my opponent was
also in time trouble so it's very
difficult to defend this
I think
I can just run the a pawn of the board
and he needs to figure out something
smart like really quickly which is not
easy with limited time on the clock yeah
it's actually hard to say how to stop
this Pawn
fun and also you still have this some
Knights right yeah exactly I still don't
see it to be honest but uh yeah yeah
this is somehow about it
yeah and after that I cannot take with a
rook of course because E3 it's a nasty
trick but yeah I can still take with a
bishop somehow but yeah this is the idea
no but but this is something no reason
to go into this yeah I must be happy
about this I think like this end game
that you got
with Bishop versus knight he must have
been very happy here yeah I think it's
just completely winning uh I played Rook
C7 somehow to force D5 yeah
not the most accurate necessarily but I
just didn't want some Rook A5 stuff yeah
but with no time for him the five I
think he had to play and now with the
Rook disconnected yeah this is just a
strong right and I think you're okay H3
yeah and here he just uh I think this is
winning basically by force like if I
calculate as well Bishop E3 the
controlling D4 yeah and here I
calculated basically until the end of
the game almost because it's all really
like uh yeah this his only idea is to
try to kick my Bishop off and go for D4
but the problem is I have
best pawns on the side of the board from
both sides basically I'll get past H
Pawn and past a pawn and the Knight is
very bad against sponsor
a or H bonds basically yeah that's kind
of useless in this type of hand game
yeah it's from both sides that's the
problem yeah
so um
yeah now H4 it's just yeah
yeah and at the end the night was even
against one time the night is pretty
useless
the king is just too far away that's the
problem I think what's up until this
point
and yeah I'm winning the night yeah so
this is where the game king of three
yeah very nice Victory by you I I do are
you a student in one of the U.S
universities or I'm not I know I'm not a
student oh you're not assistant okay
High School oh you're a high school
student okay are you looking to be
recruited to University or no well I'm
not sure yet uh I'll just see how chess
goes first and then we'll see I guess
well uh thank you so much for joining us
and good luck in the rest of your game
so we hope to see you back here thanks
for having me
so we have one have one name left in
group a which is uh the game between
Mishra and quesada Perez and we saw this
game Rich move 40 and we're expecting
this game to be
um not so good for um
for white and now we see this Pawn is
actually actually where we left off was
around here no
no no we saw all of this was all of this
so we left off around here and now we
see that this Pawn fell and now the
other Pawn is falling as well and okay
things are not going well so white is
looking for some practical chances
associated with just G7 Pawn if the Rook
manages to get to have Simon but
unfortunately this E5 pun is also
hanging
and I think here maybe even Bishop C3 is
a possibility
with the idea that here 95 on the bishop
goes to deform
but um I think this should be a quite
straightforward victory for black here
maybe even Knight P6 Knight goes to D5 I
don't see this Rook ever getting here
because the bishop will go to C3 and
take only five and black will just have
too many too much material
and the the game between
um plethora and Savion without this
final position it was three versus three
that end in an address so we have one
decisive result and we'll expect to have
another one
and in group b we saw that akshara
Chandra won and we don't have any other
decisive games so this game of
kirkazarian versus Victor michalevsky
we actually not too many developments
with Saul of this
and King F3 and then okay so White's
idea is to just try to create some kind
of a plus one here
and actually just okay King F5 it's not
a move loses a piece immediately so King
F3 I think white is quite happy if a
repetition happens here
yeah probably that's how the game is
well maybe black will try a little bit
to one
um what is the time situation so 10
versus 20. actually white is doing
really well on time
remember correctly I think
I basically always had this issue with
time management but actually it's very
good for white to be on the defensive
side of an end game and have more time
so it puts pressure on your opponent too
if there is a decision to make a draw
then maybe they should take it
and
this game of
uh what was this game
uh did I see this game oh we're starting
to look at this game oh yeah and then
so Bishop D3 Knight C6 Bishop G4 D4 was
hanging so the bishop slides back
again isolated pundit and isolated Pawn
when there's a bishop on C1 it's not so
scary
so Bishop B3 right and so white agreed
with you and put his Bishop on a
different Square yeah
uh yeah usually if the bishop it sounds
like G5 this can be pretty annoying of
course because this Pawn hangs but in
this type of structures
uh I think this can be quite okay
dream
okay so a lot of
um
pieces on the board of course the black
player does want to have piece of
activity here because they do have the
isolated Pawn
it's a knight D4
it goes back
Queen F6 there is nothing on this
diagonal yet yeah it's actually
interesting yeah it's it's funny right
because normally we think of these um uh
discoveries is is it the pin or is it a
discovery right yeah it's the queen on
F6 and the bishop and on B2 are in
contact in this case I guess Black's
Queen is having the better of the
relationship
external lights okay something
I guess it's not so scared but um so the
good thing for black is that he's left
with the correct Bishop so usually when
you have an isolated Pawn you don't want
to have the bishop that's the same color
of your palm so if your Pawn is on D5
isolated you don't know you don't want
to have a light Square Bishop so here he
has a dark Square Bishop which is good
for him and the point is you control the
squares from where the Knight can attack
you so you can capture the Knight and
this is with the pawn push yeah I guess
yeah
oh that's it 9c3 is the best way too but
uh I think he already
uh things went well yeah so just also
taking this guy
yeah you can't you can't move them
because everyone is hanging like Knight
F3 you'd like to play but you can just
play Queen A1 and
should be pretty good for black
apparently you even had Knight C3 which
was better
[Music]
so rookie one so take sticks
he doesn't hurry with grabbing upon
probably thinks he can grab it whenever
he wants to
or tonight goes back there's too many
things hanging for white
why isn't block taking a pawn
it's not greedy
okay sex
but uh was this not possible
yeah
this is okay
okay so here okay it's just playing for
initial for a second I just hallucinated
I thought this is hanging I forgot
there's a queen because usually it's a
rook only one and a queen on D1 but here
it's switched I guess he didn't want to
trade
um A3 for D5 which is why he started
with rookie eight
okay yeah there's just too many Targets
in White's position so it goes Queen E3
takes takes
Queen C2
oh this is
okay but block still has to find a way
to
Can I some of us
so you cannot go here to check and here
okay take this one
so it goes King H7 Queen V8 Queen comes
back how do we defend this pawn queen oh
wow that's a very funny move the queen
on his own defense King G7 princess five
Queen E6 oh yeah I guess
18 yeah Keen of six to E6 here and yeah
that would have been nice so he won 26.
he
thought he has a lot of activity here
so A4 B6 Queen one pack
Queen F6 okay so Rook D1 only move
rookie two goes back here it just feels
like wide position is barely hanging on
like black should have something yeah
d4b4 and a for all feel weak yeah this
whole raw font
but the thing is you know you don't have
enough for tacos you have two attackers
like I just have enough to defend queen
of sex
T2 okay
okay so now
Queen C3
so this is the position we have on the
board
um this trade must favor white because
we had three weak pawns now we have two
well I guess we can also count this
yeah so something around here happened
so here if I was a nice move if I was a
really nice result so maybe he has to
play B5 but I can imagine this is such a
hard move to play because you're also
creating this Asics weakness so maybe
something like Queen B6 Rook C1 yeah
things were like a little different
white would even be playing for a win if
you made blacks work more passive and
whites were more active it goes to show
how valuable like peace activity is and
these sorts of major piece and games
yeah I mean the problem for white is
just playing without a rook
but yeah so here
so maybe also
going after the response as possible
so if Queen C3 maybe Queen E2 again
because if we trade Queens actually it
feels like the spawns are just gonna
fall it's just this queen somehow so if
I take this queens of the board because
this Rook is just pretty useless The
Rook only comes into play when I attack
the D4 pawn and then no longer attacking
F2 it comes into play
yeah you could I mean if white black
played like Queen D2 at the end of that
line maybe Black's even like those two
one in
Rook P2 Queen C3 if I play Queen D2 I
like try to drop the screen yeah Queen
D2 is a huge threat in this position
this looks very very tough or white
but the position that we have I think
white has survived
the words maybe actually it's still not
clear because of some one of the pawns
hangs if the four Pawn Falls then the
spawn
will clean maybe when Queen
no but Queen D3 uh you can go whichever
Pawn you tickle yeah I'll take the other
one until end in a draw and if you went
for this this is why I went here so I
would have this Rook C5
I can do this yeah
so black has some winning chances but
probably white has survived uh the worst
of the storm
um yeah I guess we should uh take a look
at the standings for the A and B groups
um let's start with group a
So Daniel Dar uh darta has a win and
there's a so he is in clear first at the
moment though we have a game pending it
seems likely that Yasser quesada Perez
will also tie for first and then there's
a big uh there's a a big potentially
six way tie for second place Sam said
again ilionic Benjamin Ghidorah Daria
Schwartz uh nordebec uh Chris for you
and Benjamin Bach or sorry not Benjamin
block but Christopher you all have half
a point out of their first game
and let's take a look add grip Group B
so so far we have only one decisive
result with akshat Chandra winning his
game in a really nice fashion with that
Queen D1 move that Lisa and our other
game is a draw between Jason Liang and
tambasaur and bobseren and the rest of
the games are going but from what we saw
so far where maybe there will be
decisive result in this game we're
looking at between gergelic Hunter and
Luca Buddhism levage but I think maybe
closer to a draw and of course in the
other games again this game against
turkazayan and Victor mikhalevsky some
developments but we're also thinking
white should be able to hold that and
finally this other game that where black
had some very good chances but looks
like white was able to consolidate and
again I think closer to ending in a draw
dancing or decides a result yeah so some
uh most of the games have ended in draws
but some decisive games and definitely
some very exciting chess even in the
games that were drawn be sure to join us
tomorrow at 4 pm Central Time on YouTube
twitch and also uschess
champs.com thanks for tuning in and see
you guys tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited